my name is Camila and thank you all for
coming
so as the title says the taught the
title of my talk is a tube story which
is in a nod to the classic 1970s film a
love story which I haven't seen but
people tell me it's about two people who
love each other very much so this talk
is going to be about my love for the
London Underground right
so roughly I'm going to divide this talk
into three parts the first part is going
to be a bit about my motivation so why
would you want to study the London
Underground and what kind of questions
Mike you want to answer like what kind
of questions might you want to ask about
the London Underground in the second
part I'm going to talk about graph tool
which is a Python library that allows
you to analyze graphs and then in the
third part I'm going to talk a bit about
sin pi which is a simulation library
that you can use to create various kinds
of simulations for example simulations
of the London Underground right and just
to note before we start simple should
not be confused with sin pi which
confusingly sounds exactly the same but
sin PI over the Y is a symbolic
computation library whereas sin PI with
an eye is a simulation library and
someone on the internet told me that you
should actually pronounce sin pi the
simulation library as simpie but I won't
be able to do that with a straight face
so I hope never mind
I'll keep calling and sin PI I'm not
gonna say something that's just really
good I'm sorry do whoever came up with
that name okay so before we dive into
talk just a little bit about my
background so I graduated in 2014 from a
small university just outside
Philadelphia and I spent a year at
Edinboro mostly wearing a lot of heavy
rain gear but also sometimes writing
some Python and after that I moved to
London and took up a job as a data
plumber which basically means I moved
data and create some minor disasters
occasionally right so my story really
starts in August 2014
when I first moved to London and my
first home was located somewhere around
near Edgware Road and my job was located
at Liverpool Street so here I was this
was my first day and having lived in
Edinburgh for a year I was really
unprepared for the challenges of
commuting in a large city so I thought
okay at 8 a.m. I'll just go to Edgware
Road station and I'll catch the Circle
Line and everything's gonna be fine
so this is a bit this is how I thought
it would look you know a few people it's
gonna be okay so here I go I arrived at
Edgware Road at 8:00 a.m. and I quickly
realized that one does not simply board
the train at 8:00 a.m.
in fact I had to let around 6 trains go
before I could finally squeeze myself
into a 720 it was not a very pleasant
experience and I was almost late for my
first day of work which also is not a
very pleasant experience right but you
know after a few weeks my tube savvy
level you know gets up so as the number
of commutes Rises so does your number of
commuting hacks that you acquire so
these are basically hopeful rules that
will help you navigate the London
Underground in the most efficient manner
for example my top three rules for the
first month is boarded edge road before
7:30 this will guarantee you a place on
the tube without having to feel like us
her name the second one which I had to
learn the hard way twice never attempt
to board anything at Victoria because it
will never happen forever and then if
you come to the station and you see that
funky looking table with all those
severe delays you might as well just go
back to sleep because it ain't gonna
happen right so I am these rooms were
fairly successful at you know getting me
to work on time but I realized that
sometimes they didn't work because
actually the flow of commuters on the
London Underground can behave quite
erratically depending on what's going on
so some days I would come to a Dorota
bit late side comma dates and all of a
sudden I was expecting to see this huge
crowd but then there is no one
I'm standing there and I'm thinking okay
is this a bank holiday I'm actually
supposed to be still in bed or did the
ticket Barry accidentally teleport me to
an alternative universe then on some
other days I come to a Jew road at 7:30
and there's a ton of people and I'm like
okay what is going on so it seems to me
that sometimes on the tube network you
can have distance signal failures or
congestion zhan distance lines that can
then ripple throughout the network
because people are routed from one
particular section of the network to
another and thus even though your
particular area of the underground
network is working well the extra
pressure from all the commuters coming
from other net other parts of the
network that aren't functioning well can
cause congestion in fact this has
already been studied quite well by
professors around the world and if
you're interested to learn about the
flow patterns and commuter networks in
urban transportation you can read this
excellent book by Professor Chaffee from
MIT I've linked to it from the slide so
what Professor Chaffee writes is that
the flow pattern in an urban
transportation network basically depends
on two competing mechanisms so first of
all there are the users there are the
very stressed London commuters that want
to get to work as fast as possible and a
user always tries to minimize the cost
of their travel so this is not
necessarily the cost of your Oyster card
or your pay as you go
that's the fashionable fashionable
people do it nowadays but this can be
pretty much anything
this can be your time time taken to
travel from point A to point B or for
example how frustrating it is or how
many times you have to change train so
cost can be measured in a variety of
different ways now if cost of traveling
would stay constant throughout the day
it would be quite easy for every user to
optimize their path unfortunately the
second competing mechanism that
determines these flow patterns is
basically the change in the cost of
travel according to the load and anyone
who's commuted at 8 a.m. or at 5 p.m.
knows what I'm talking
commuting during rush hour is
significantly more stressful than
commuting at let's say 2:00 p.m. when
there is no one so keeping this in mind
I came up with two questions that I
wanted to answer so I wanted to know
what are the most important stations on
the Underground so what are the key
critical stations where if a disruption
were to occur you would pretty much
screw up everybody's commute and
secondly I wanted to sort of start
quantifying how disruption of these
stations would affect the rest of the
network and this is basically what I'll
be talking about in part two and part
three of the talk so in part two I'm
going to use graph tool which is a which
is an excellent Python library to
perform some static graph analysis on
the London Underground Network before we
can do that however we need to collect
some data so I am an extremely lazy data
plumber and here is my life pro tip do
not reinvents the data file use Google
so in this case I tried to Google for a
convenient data file where someone would
have basically defined every single
station on the London Underground and
then somehow made it easy to parse that
into Python and then generate a graph
unfortunately my Google foo level wasn't
high enough so I was not able to find
this file instead I had to make a strong
cup of coffee and write it myself so
basically this is what the file looks
like
for every single of the almost 300
stations on the underground you
basically define the station you define
its neighbors and then the tube lines
that go to those neighbors and I just
realized that I misspelled Piccadilly
line
I apologize Tony Piccadilly line fans
this was not intentional it's a
difficult word anyway so this is what my
data file looks like and you can then
write some simple Python functions to
parse this into a graph object so let's
start by examining some graph tool
basics so first of all if we want to
create a graph we need to create a blank
graph object and this is done quite
simply by calling the wrap constructor
as you can see
do we have a pointer okay you're just
going to have to imagine me pointing at
that box anyway so we have a blank graph
object and then we can add some vertices
to that graph by calling surprised you
guessed it add vertex right there and
you also want to add some edges so this
kind of very simple setup works well for
small graphs but then for large
real-life applications you also want to
create something called a property map
for example in my case I wanted to
associate the names of the stations with
the vertices that represented them and I
wanted to associate the names of the
tube lines with the edges to represented
them so graph tool provides a very
convenient object for this called the
property map which you can create for
either vertices or edges by calling the
new vertex property function in addition
to calling the function you also need to
pass the type of the value that you will
be associating so if you want to
associate names of stations with their
vertices you have to pass a string but
it can pretty much be anything so for
example if you want to associate with
each station the number of commuters
that enters that station during the day
you could create a vertex property map
using integers right so now comes the
fun part at least for me when you're
dealing with graphs it's always fun to
draw them and visualize them and graph
tool offers you a lot of different ways
that you can do that so the simplest one
that I picked and their work for me was
the graph draw function you simply pass
your graph into it and you can pass a
bunch of other keyword arguments that
you know define the colors of the
vertices or the lengths of the edges or
the positions of the vertices and pretty
much anything you want so if you're
interested in tweaking your graphs I
encourage you to look at the graph tool
documentation it's actually pretty good
so the the sort of standard graph draw
works quite well for for a small graph
you know
you get these these nice graphics and it
also works really well for networks that
are regular in the sense that they're
generated by some kind of model for
example here is a series of graphs drawn
with graph draw of the price network so
it looks quite pretty but when you're
dealing with something when you're
dealing with graph data that comes from
a real life application you really can't
have nice pictures because you're going
to have a lot of nodes that are going to
bunch together and the edges are going
to be intersecting so how do we
visualize is the London Underground in
an efficient manner so we have the
standard TFO map which is more or less
confusing sometimes or helpful depending
on your visual skills I suppose and then
we also have the geographic locations of
the maps not the maps the stations which
I've plotted here using bouquet and I've
colored them according to the zone so
that you look fairly familiar after that
I try to do some visualizations using
graph draw and I came up with less than
impressive result so visualizing messy
graphs is whoa it's it's messy and as
you can see you can't really tell
anymore where is the Bakerloo line or
the central lines just all one one mess
also adding graph adding vertex labels
is quite impossible for a graph of
almost three hundred nodes so what can
you do about this one strategy is to try
out some different layout algorithms and
graph to is actually quite good it
provides you with at least four
different layout algorithms so SFTP you
fracture man Reingold
ARF and then radio layout and most of
these are based on the idea that the
objects in a graph form a physical
system and so you are trying to find the
layout that basically minimizes the
energy I'm not an expert in this but you
could probably tweak some parameters in
the graph to layout algorithm that would
give you nice and results but
fortunately I wasn't able to
but I'm going to show you how you might
want to go about creating such a layout
so once again graph tool makes it very
easy so you simply call the SMTP layout
function and you pass in your graph as a
parameter and that returns to you our
familiar property map object which Maps
each vertex in your graph to a position
that is computed by this algorithm and
then you simply pass in your position to
the graph draw function using the POS
keyword so I did some experiments and
this is the London Underground
visualized in more or less creative ways
I mean they are quite pretty but their
value for the data analyst is is not
that great but I'll just let you stare
in awe for a few seconds ok right so I
decided that the best way at least for
my project was to simply plot on the
stations based on their geographic
coordinates so that I was Li I would at
least know you know what's going on in
zone 1 and zone 2 and so forth
ok so in addition to making pretty
pictures which may not be so useful we
want to get some statistics luckily
graph tool comes to comes to our rescue
there as well so in order to compute the
degree distribution which is a common
metric used to characterize networks we
can either call a the vertex hist method
in the stats Mario or then we can simply
iterate through all the vertices and
call the outdegree method on each vertex
to return the out degree or in degree if
that's what you want and then this
enables you to pass this list basically
to pandas and plotter with Seabourn or
whatever is your preferred method so
this is the degree the out degree
distribution of the London Underground
network and as expected most stations
have a very low number of out degree and
you can see the reason for that in this
picture most of the stations in zone 3
to 6 belong to only one two blind
so they'll only have you know the one
out degree going northbound and once
have found our East or West depending on
where you are okay so if we go back to
the two questions that I defined at the
beginning so I wanted to examine what
are some of the most important nodes in
the London Underground and one way to do
that is to compute computer property
known as centrality and there are
actually a few different flavors of this
property so one of them is between a
centrality and roughly speaking it
defines what fraction of all shortest
paths pass through a given node so if a
station has a high betweenness
centrality this might suggest that a
large number of commuters would pass
through that station during a given day
so this is very easy to do using graph
tool as I'm sorry anyway I'll come back
to how you do that but in addition to
between us centrality we can also
compute something called the closeness
centrality and you compete closeness
centrality for a node by summing it the
distance from that node to all other
nodes and then taking the reciprocal of
that sum so if a node is fairly close to
all other nodes in the network then its
closeness centrality will be quite high
anyway so you can compute betweenness
quite easily it's simply just one
function call that returns to you both
the vertex between us as a property map
and the edge between us as a property
map and then you can type that into your
further downstream analysis likewise for
a closeness centrality it's just a
matter of literally calling one function
and then you're done so how does between
the centrality look like for the London
Underground so that the blue graph is
something that I got from graph draw and
the size of the vertex is directly
proportional to the between the
centrality of that node so as you can
see the nodes that are sort of close to
closings of the nodes that are located
in zone
have a high betweenness centrality as
you might expect because zone 1 contains
stations such as Baker Street and Kings
Cross that are basically the
intersections of I think five different
tube lines so it would make sense for a
lot of commuters to go through those
stations this this map is a bouquet map
of the London Underground where the
shade of red that each vertex is is
directly proportional to its betweenness
centrality so the more red something is
the higher its value is and as you might
suspect most of the high betweenness
centrality vertices are in zone one
except for this little outlier right
here can anyone guess what that station
might be it's in zone one and some the
Bakerloo line
all right that's that's quite close to
actually Marylebone so Marylebone is
stay alone the outlier anyway so when we
sort the values we see that the top
stations for between the centrality are
as expected Baker Street Kings Cross and
Liverpool Street and I have to confess
my line doesn't fit weird but it's quite
far east oh I don't really see any
rational intuitive reason why why it
would be high on this list but it is so
then closeness centrality which is I
remind you basically measures how close
on average a notice to all other nodes
in the network and the list looks quite
different so this time the top stations
are Green Park Oxford Circus and Vaughan
Street you can also see that the
distribution of values is different so
for between a centrality you have quite
if you have quite a little small number
of stations that are very high in the
list and then everyone else has a really
low between the centrality whereas for
closeness centrality you can see that
most of the nodes in this image are
actually very dark red so what this
might suggest is that there are very few
critical stations measured by
betweenness centrality but actually most
stations in
London Underground Network are pretty
close to each other so no matter where
you entered the network you you can
still travel to other parts quite fast
how am i doing on time okay
so that's a very basic answer to what
are the most important stations in the
London Underground network and the
second question that I wanted to answer
is what happens if we suspend one of
those stations I mean apart from chaos
we all know chaos is going to happen but
if we want to sort of quantify it and to
do that we have to mask some of the
stations in our network and we're lucky
in the sense that graph 2 actually
provides a convenient filtering method
to do this so you can temporarily mask
edges and vertices without actually
removing them from the graph which is
quite convenient you do that by creating
an edge or vertex property map and
simply setting true for all the vertices
that you want to keep and false for all
the vertices that you want masked so
this opens up an avenue to creating
interactive graphics by using graph
tools filtering functions and then using
bouquet so you'll have bouquet on the
front end sort of driving the
visualization and you you can type in
the name of station to filter out and
then that request is going to be sent to
the back end where a graph tool will do
some computing and update the
betweenness values and then send them
back to bouquet so this is what it might
look like so you can make an app with a
map of the London Underground which is
colored by between a centrality to
illustrate the most critical stations
and then you can have a small text box
where you enter the name of the station
and then it's masked as if there would
be a signal failure at that station and
no one could travel there so for example
if we remove Baker Street we can see in
the original image that all of the line
all of those stations here have a fairly
low between the centrality but once you
remove Baker
three there is a lot more commuter
traffic being routed to every single
station right here so that might suggest
that the traffic patterns would be
indeed quite different in Baker Street
would be suspended for some reason so
you can also try this with Mailand
and you can see some similar effects
we're removing my line would basically
put more commuter pressure on some other
neighboring stations
so to summarize graph two is pretty
awesome
it lets you fly with fairly few lines of
code you can create a modify graphs you
can visualize them although that's not
very useful sometimes but you know
pretty pictures are pretty pictures you
can also compute statistics and
interesting metrics and filter nodes and
do a lot more that I don't really have
time to cover okay so on we go and on to
part three so doing static analysis of
of graphs is all good and well but we
also want to get into some simulations
and to do that we need to employ some PI
so this is an open source discrete event
simulation library that was originally
conceived by Klaus Muller and Tony Reno
and it is now in in version 3.0 so there
are four cornerstones to creating a
simple simulation at least a very simple
one and they are environment resources
processes and events and during this
talk I'll be talking about three of them
so environment resources and processes
right so let's get started with the
first one so the environment is the
command center of your simulation the
environment will take processes or
agents that you want to simulate and
then schedule and suspend them according
to the logic that you code so you simply
create an environment by calling simply
environment constructor then you add
some events and processes and you're
sort of start button in this simulation
is the run call to which you can supply
the optional keyword arguments until
which basic
we specifies how many steps your
simulation does before it stops so next
up are processes so if you want to be
really formal processes are the stuff
that does some stuff with some other
stuff in your simulation so this is
formulas this is going to get anyway if
you want to be a bit less formal
they are Python generator functions that
alternate between an active and a
passive state and unfortunately I don't
have time to talk about generators they
absolutely Rock but I've linked this
talk which is from Python 2014 and it is
quite mind-blowing so I do recommend
watching it so if you want to create a
simple simulation of the London
Underground we might want to create a
train process so let's create a simple
train process that is going to travel
between stations for three time units
and then spend four time units on the
platform boarding commuters so here is
the high-level overview of how that's
going to happen so you're going to
import some PI you're going to create a
generator function which is going to be
your process and then you're going to do
some other magic to get the simulation
started and I'll go through this in
detail so first of all we're creating a
training process with two events
traveling between stations for three
time units and then spending four time
units on a platform boarding commuters
so these are basically events that you
yield using the yield keyword so when
this function execution hits the yield
keyword the process will be suspended so
the environment will say okay train now
you have to travel for three time units
between stations before I'll resume you
so and the environment will keep track
of this time and after three time units
it will wake up train again so train
won't print arriving on station and then
it will yield another timeout event for
four time units which will represent the
boarding off commuters after that
you simply create the environment you
schedule the process by passing it as an
argument to the process function and
then you basically just hit the start
button and run the simulation and you
should get an output of something like
that so this is a very lame train it
only travels one signboards commuters
once so if you just want to take our
brief step step by step to how this
train works so first the function is
going to start executing it's going to
print start travel then it's going to
yield this timeout event so that will
basically represent the times of the
Train spans between platforms then the
environment is going to wake up train
again it's going to print arriving at
station and it's going to yield a
timeout again which will represent the
time that it spends on the platform so
we can also make this a bit cooler by
creating an infinite loop infinito turn
off cool but in this case they are so
instead you can control how much you're
assuming your simulation executes by
passing different parameters to the
untell keyword so for example this
simulation will only simulate for 30
time units before it stops and you can
see the result there you can also go
wild and you can say okay let's create
an underground network with two trains
so we're going to create an additional
parameter in the function and we're
going to create two different trains in
circle line that travels for a one time
unit and spends four time units boarding
commuters and then in Northern Line that
spends six time unit traveling and two
time units boarding commuters and we
pass both of these to the environment to
tell the environment that okay these are
our processes and we want you to start
simulating them so basically you should
get an output that is something like
that so that was all four processes and
next is probably the coolest thing about
senpai is resources so what our
resources resources are the stuff that's
consumed by other stuff so basically
space
on a train space on a platform or
available ticket barriers if we're
talking about the London Underground
when truly it could be anything it could
be gas palm to the gas station or have
no chairs in a room some like that so
there are three different flavors of
resources and the first one is a vanilla
resource which is basically like a gas
pump at a gas station it can be used by
a limited number of processes at a time
the second one is a container type which
is a bulk resource such as gasoline and
the third one is a store which is a more
exotic research type that can consume
and produce Python objects so previously
we created two entrained processes now
let's try to create a platform which can
only be used by one train at a time so
how we do how do we do this we create a
simple resource by calling the resource
constructor then inside our circle train
process we create a request by calling
platform request so this point the train
is requesting the platform for a space
to approach and we yield that request
which basically goes off into the
environment and says hey environment
this train is approaching the platform
so can it approach organs that have to
wait and after the Train receives
permission to approach the environment
will resume the circling process and the
train will start boarding commuters so
this is how it looks pictorially and
sort of the one thing that you have to
remember is that you have to release
your resources what happens in this case
when we have one train is that it is
going to request this resource and then
it's going to arrive at the platform and
start traveling again and then at time 6
is going to request the platform again
but it's going to stay in the limbo
because you forgot to release the
platform from the previous time that it
arrived at the station so this is just
something to keep in mind if you start
playing around with resources so you
have to always remember to release
or use a context manager if you don't
trust your memory right so just to
summarize briefly because I'm running
out of time
Simba has an environment which is the
command center
it has processes that do things with
other things and then it has resources
which are things consumed by processes
now if you want to be really cool you
can bring this all together the three
libraries that we talked about you can
use graph tool to compute the shortest
paths for commuters entering your
network you can use Simba to create
commuter and train processes in a
fashion that I just showed you and then
you can use boquete to visualize and
results in a real-time so for example
this is a screenshot from a VOC a
simulation that basically illustrates
the number of commuters at each station
as a function of time so the larger the
littles the circles are the more
commuters are currently waiting for a
train of that station so you can see
that it changes and I've included a
video screenshot demo if you want to see
how that actually works in in real time
so that was all thank you very much
questions are comments are welcome or if
you just want to tell me what your
favorite tube station is that's fine as
well
Thank You Camilla any questions yes one
word speed okay I mean if you go to the
graph tool documentation I mean this
might be a little bit biased because it
is the graph to a documentation you'll
see a comparison between graph two and
network X in terms of execution speed
and if I remember correctly Network X is
a pure Python like an application but
graph two under the hood is actually
runs in C++ so speed if that's what you
care about
exactly so now there is there is there
is a game that some people play with I
don't like red this is going 24-hour
period to visit every single tube stop
right yes sometimes it becomes
impossible because you get the choke
points in the system where either it's
very hard to get onto the train it comes
slow or the rest of it this seems like
the perfect solution to firstly working
out what could possibly be the shortest
time to visit every single cheap stock
but also where to start
and perhaps you know some of the
inflection points where I've got to make
a chance you know probability between
where I jump between the lines so that
is actually an excellent question and I
have been researching this is called the
tube challenge and I think it was broken
in 2011 I think the record was eight
hours so something like that yeah and it
was done by a guy who was a marathon
runner so when he would get to the last
last station in a tube bike he would you
know run to the to the beginning of the
other line so you have to be quite fit
but graph tool does include something
called a traveling salesman solver which
I guess use of some heuristics to to
perhaps suggest an optimal path so if
you want to go down to a booth
then I wish you luck and you can try a
graph tool and you know do some data
science on it very good any more
questions
yes absolutely so that's a great
question and you know in the mornings
most people travel to London and then in
the afternoons at rivers so that is
definitely something that you can do and
you can include weights on the vertices
to help you decide that I wanted to do a
distinction because I wanted the
outgoing traffic from the station to be
different from there in going traffic so
if you have a station that has more
people going out on a train then you
might want to separate it into two
different edges but you don't have to
you can do an undirected graph yes if
that's what you yeah you can do
that's okay random musings are welcome a
lost question that's a hard one hmm I'm
probably going to have the same
Marylebone that I think it's it's quite
it's quite freaky well they have it
Halle Berry is auditioning freakiest
Jeep scientist so Pat thank you very
much